twice a week for 26 years
len burke and his wife llewellyn have
made the trip from the suburbs
into new york city where len has gone to
work at
zabar's the famous gourmet food emporium
this place is like a second home to me
so when zaybar
sent him home for a year during the
pandemic
it was len says kind of traumatic
but i had my two shots so i'm back
he's back slicing locks cutting
paper-thin
slices of smoked salmon with his 18-inch
knife and len's return is notable
because his next birthday will be his
92nd
did you think he'd still be working at
92 i never thought i would be 92.
it's a very strange place to be let me
tell you
things change yeah they don't get better
but
but you're still here i'm still plugging
away a native new yorker
len was an accountant in his first
career
then after he sold his practice a friend
of mine
called me up and said it was an ad in
the new york times
that zabar's was looking for a slicer
and i've been here ever since what's
your most memorable day here ben
the day i had
kind of a little argument with itzhak
perlman
len and the grammy-winning conductor
fought over
cookies it's a long story we agreed to
disagree
he's a lovely man he's also served jerry
seinfeld
and glenn close anybody else lauren
mccall
he missed all of that when he was away
it was not good to pass the time
len wrote a song about his eventual
return to work
sung to the tune of the second time
around
lox is loxier the second time around
come to zay bars and buy yourself a
pound
what's the secret to being a good slicer
love
i think it's really the secret to being
a good enemy if you
love what you do yeah it's wonderful
so you got to be in love with the salmon
well that that's pretty tricky
i do continue my search for the perfect
slice
it's elusive is it very elusive if i
see it i'll know it is that the day you
retire
no i'm not going to retire no for len
burke
the lure of lox is simply too strong
i feel at times i'm one with the salmon